we call this third and short three rapid
fire questions for rodney we'll see how
rapid we can keep it first one reads
pick one word to describe
ryan fitzpatrick comes back into the
game to play quarterback against las
vegas and gets the win one word to
describe the performance out of
fitzpatrick
i would say
perseverance
or toughness
yeah i would say toughness because when
think about it jack think about it he's
getting his head ripped off by a 300
pound defensive lineman look at it okay
and he still got the wherewithal to
steal the mental capacity still
experience to try to throw the ball down
the field and complete he already knew
that he was going to be okay with the
penalty i love this guy man and you know
what i love most about him is his
humility when they were interviewing him
and you know they tried to ask him some
tough questions should he start he says
look
we trust our head coach and whatever he
decides that's what we're going to roll
with and tua and i we're going to both
support each other and i think that's
the reason why this has worked out so
well you look at ryan fitzpatrick and i
just listened to his interview i just
just shook my head i was like wow this
guy is an incredible guy i've never got
a chance to meet him but i've always
been a fan of all the heart and just how
tough he's he he's been and how he can
come in off the bench and you know make
electric plays i've always been just a
admirer of um brian fitzpatrick
i don't know how you could be and the
mentor that he's been to tua and even if
he's come into a game he always just
relinquishes that power of the starting
quarterback position back to two just to
make sure that he continues to build up
the young man which you gotta love all
those things for me the performance has
to be somewhere between fearless and
flawless uh and that's when you get the
best from ryan fitzpatrick and i was
talking to an offensive coordinator one
time that coach fitzpatrick in buffalo
and he said the same thing that makes
ryan fitzpatrick one of the best
quarterbacks in the league when he's
playing at his peak
is the same thing that can make him one
of the worst when he's falling apart and
it is that he has never seen a window
that he doesn't believe he can fit it
into and he's not some huge arm
quarterback i mean this isn't some you
know some great brett favre aaron
rodgers patrick mahomes type arm but he
always believes he can fit it in there
and he never waits there's no hesitation
to him even in the end of this vegas
game thinking back to the seam route
where he just put up 40 yards down the
field in a perfect location he gets it
there because he believes he can and
then you come back with he's getting his
head spun around he completes another
one down the sideline i mean nine of 13
182 and a touchdown to go get the win
after you've been sitting on the bench
all game and it wasn't like two was
playing bad two was keeping a minute
playing a efficient football but he
wasn't pushing the ball down the field
and as soon as fitzpatrick came in he
brought that fearless nature to him
started pushing the ball down the field
and that's what got him the win they had
to come from behind twice to go get this
thing done
hey you know it's funny because you just
answered my question because i was going
to ask you a question it's like as soon
as he came in what did you see from him
and that's exactly what i saw as soon as
he came down because tua was managing
the game like we always talk about
dinking and dunking running a football
but as soon as fitch came in he just
started slinging that thing down the
field it was really good to see my
question to you though i'm a transition
to my question to you is
who do you start
if you're brian flores who do you start
it's one of the hardest it's one of the
hardest quarterback calls it's it's not
historically i'm not in on two
quarterback systems and i i don't like
it
but man if i'm down i'd rather start
fitzpatrick i'd rather play fitzpatrick
and if i'm winning if i have a lead i'd
rather be playing two so take that for
what it's worth i think i probably would
start tua and if i got way behind i'd
probably bring back in fitzpatrick and
see if he could go do something for me
what would you do i have no clue this is
hard now
no no no you don't know because i asked
coach dungy the same thing last night
and i asked him and he said the same
exact thing and i i was wondering
because i'm like okay i was kind of
caught up on the fitzpatrick bandwagon
and he kind of brought me down to
reality he says look and just like you
said he says tua was playing very solid
football he wasn't making a lot of big
plays down the field but he he wasn't
hurting him
so he was like hey i'm going to start
tour and if he happens to struggle or we
feel like we need a boost we know where
we can go so
i
i like it i wouldn't start fitzpatrick
but i will i would start um tour and
allow him to come in and do his thing
you know if you know whatever happens
happens
i love it let's get to number two
true or false travis kelsey so he has a
44-yard lead to become the first tight
end to ever lead the league in receiving
so he has a 44-yard lead over deandre
hopkins only problem is how much will he
i mean you tell me how much he'll play
so true or false travis kellis becomes
the first tight end to actually get this
thing done and finish out the entire
season on top of the league in receiving
i'm gonna say false because i think
deandre hopkins in order for them to win
next week he has to have a monster game
and they have to win and i don't know if
they need help or whatever the situation
is uh let me think clint's play off with
a win yeah they clinched the playoff
with the win
but this guy is absolutely amazing he's
worked hard this entire year if i'm andy
reid i don't know if i'm taking a chance
of putting my big tight end out there
i'm you know he andy reed came out and
talked about he's gonna arrest some of
his veteran players this is a guy that
puts it all on the line he i mean he
sacrifices his body
he's um he's just such a good football
player man and i i don't know if i would
risk this
because i like to see them healthy and
fresh i know they have the number one
seed maybe he plays the first half maybe
comes out the second half but if if i'm
andy reid i don't know if i would take a
chance on risking his um health to go
for a record
you can't you can't and especially
somebody i think the most
if you want to get specific he has had
concussion issues in the past and
especially before a playoff push there's
no way i'm even remotely risking some
sideways shot anything that travis
kelsey could take they would that would
i mean it just doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if he ends up leading the league
and receiving or hopkins does makes no
difference and this is the playoff
favorite by a substantial margin
something that we've covered and he is
such a key to that i mean only a handful
of games this year where he's exploded
over 100 yards but he's so consistent
he's always in that about 70 to 90 range
where he never takes the game off and
that's how you end up hanging out right
at the top of the league
go ahead rob you know i was going to say
i have a lot of respect for this man the
way he plays the game
i was fortunate enough i've gone against
hall of famers like antonio gates jason
whitton tony gonzalez shannon sharp the
list goes on
and you think about all those great
players and they were phenomenal players
but he's a better route runner than all
those guys it's not even close
it's not even close and you see guys
jamming them they're trying to play off
and the way he just does his routes and
he pushes off and how smooth he is and
everything that touches his hands he
catches plus he's a really tall guy
i always say you got to double team him
i don't i don't know if there's one guy
in this league that could probably take
him away maybe jalen ramsey could
could do a halfway decent job on him but
most linebackers safeties and
cornerbacks cannot stick this guy he's
just simply unguardable
and you think about also how great their
wide receivers are and the running backs
that they could bring out of the
backfield elaire le'veon bell the amount
of different places that mahomes can go
with the football for the tight end to
be leading not only his team but leading
the entire nfl and receiving points to
how great he must be i think the
relationship that he's developed with
the young patrick mahomes and they spend
a whole bunch of time in the off season
take vacations together i think they you
know the couples if you will both of
their girlfriends now fiance soon to be
wife of patrick holmes they're all very
close so they just spent a ton of time
together
and that's translated onto the field i
mean so you have the best quarterback
the young best quarterback in the league
pairing up with what all the things he
could do it's a special combination one
that we'll talk about for a long time
i'm sure let's get to the third one
alvin kamara
alvin kamara or christian mccaffrey
today if you could redraft it they're
both the same pick if you will who would
you prefer to have you're starting your
franchise there rod well i'm gonna
probably go with alvin kamara um and
this was a tough one because i have a
lot of respect for christian mccaffrey i
played against his dad ed mccaffrey who
was a was tough as nails was a big long
range wide receiver and he's to come and
chase me and kick my butt all the time
but i would have to go with alvin kamar
i just think his i just think his
running style um
you know in christians he's had some
problems with some injuries and things
like that but alvin kamara is an
absolute stud and to be able to get a
guy like that in the third round you
don't have to spend a first round pick
on him yes you made him the highest paid
running back i think in league history
um
you know but both these guys are
outstanding i hate questions like this
but my answer is definitely alvin kamara
on this one what about you
so the reason why this question came
about and i had to ask when i saw it in
the rundown is that sean payton and now
it's gotten even louder of course but
during the draft process was saying that
camaro was a better running back than
christian mccaffrey mccaffrey of course
was all the buzz he was going to be a
first round pick he was top of the
league everybody was going crazy about
him but he was stuck on kamara coming
out of tennessee and of course was gonna
go much later and now you've seen the
way that this has played out now yeah
i'm coming off a record-setting
touchdown performance game and as great
as kamara was and has been what always
stands out to me is he's such a calm
runner he's just so calm everybody else
looks like they're running around 115
miles per hour and he looks like he's
about 65 in cruise control sitting back
sipping a coffee but still they can't
tackle them and so there's just no way
to really get a hand on a guy that's
that calm and he'll stiff arm and he'll
put a foot in the ground here that's
what's so impressive but i think you
have to give credit to this offensive
line so when i went back and looked at
the grades of ram check armstead eric
mccoy troutman they're blocking tight
end ruiz their right guard all of these
guys were 80s
70s or 90s and run blocking grade so
that's a big reason why he's hitting
that second level untouched and then
able to create some of that magic that
he's so great at
yeah both these guys are really great
players i'm hoping christian mccaffrey
man just think about if they would had
him if they would have had him this year
as hard as carolina plays and what matt
rule is doing down there um building
with dj moore and robbie anderson and
all those guys mike davis he's done a
really great job
in place of christian mccaffrey but i
can't wait to see this young man back on
the field next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports